كيف ستبدو هذه الحرب بين الصين والولايات
المتحده حول وقوعها بسبب تايواننا
وضع تصورا لبعض العوائق امام الطرفين ما
هي مركز دراسات امريكيه اجرى مناوره
افتراضيه العمل الماضي تحاكي هجوما
برمائيا صينيا على تايوان وحينها نفذ
مخزون صواريخ كروز بعيده المدى المضاده
للسفن من الجانب الامريكي في غضون اسبوع
على الطرف الصيني تبدو القوه الصاروخيه
الصينيه مجهزه جدا لامطار القواعد
والموانئ التي تعتمد عليها الولايات
المتحده في المنطقه مناوره حربيه اجرتها
هيئه الاركان في البانتاجون اظهرت ان
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان تعرقل غزوه
صينيا لتايوان اذا جرت الحرب في وقت لاحق
من هذا العقد الا انها لن تستطيع ايقافه
ولتحضير للمستقبل
تخلص بل تخلص السلاح مشاه البحريه من
دباباته ويعيد تشكيل نفسه كقوه تهاجم
السفن الصينيه من الجزر الصغيره في غرب
المحيط الهادئ وسيتم تجهيزه بصواريخ مضاده
للسفن في جزيره اوكينا والياباني بحلول
عام 20 25 نبقى في البحر وفيه تواجه
البحريه الامريكيه قيودا على قدره بناء
السفن وتخطط حاليا لتوسيع اسطولها الى ما
لا يقل عن 355 سفينه ماهوله
لمواكبه التطور البحري الصيني بكين من
جانبها تواصل تطوير قواتها الجويه التي
تعتبر اصغر من مثيلتها الامريكيه واختبرت
اكثر من مره صواريخ جديده تفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت
[موسيقى]